[Applaudissements]
on enchaîne les
surprises j'adore j'adore j'adore cette
émission génial
allô allô bonsoir bon je sais déjà c'est
pour Daniel ça pour Guillaume ça m'a
l'air bien oui bonsoir bonsoirons vous
êtes venu donc pour faire une surprise à
une personne autour de la table enfin
autour sur du plateau d'accord euh
est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut avoir un
premier indice s'il vous plaît alors la
personne sur le plateau était amoureux
ou amoureuse de moi plus jeune ah oh bon
bah ça c'est où Raymon ou Guillaume
jenton
c'est ça je je je je je tape bien pour
l'instant peut-être ouais plutôt ouais
plutôt oui plôt d'accord est-ce qu'on
peut avoir un deuxième indice alors
sachez que j'ai vendu énormément de
disques dans les années 90 ah ah ah ah
vous êtes une fille ou un garçon euh à
vous de deviner bah au niveau de la voix
je dirais
plusille une fille une femme oh une
femme waouh wou une femme et il y a ou
rmon ou Guillaume Janton qui était
amoureux de
vous ah je sens vous avez vous avez
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire nous
donner un de vos titres
pH
pourquoi pour pourquoi pourquoi tout ça
n'arrive qu'à moi et pourquoi Valentino
chez toi
j'ad Valentino
moi elle est où alors elle est là alors
elle n elle n'est pas sur le plateau
elle est actuellement attendez attendez
parce que c'est une très grosse surprise
elle est actuellement en showcase privé
et elle est en showcase privé mais on va
quand même la retrouver en showocc privé
parce qu'on a pu faire un duplexe juste
pour qu'elle vous dise bonjour bonsoir
Sandy tu peux tu peux alors allez en
showcase privé chez quelqu'un vous
reconnaissez oui c'est chez vous
ah oui on a on a on a récupéré les clés
de chez vous et elle est en chocage chez
vous regardez ah ou oui oui regardez
alors c'est chez Guillaume regardez donc
c'est qui ça c'est qui ça c'est le Père
Noël bordel bordel oui c'est chez
Guillaume pré allez-y est-ce qu'elle est
là Sandy est-ce qu'elle peut faire le
showcase de chez Guillaume s'il vous
plaît du
merci oui voà c'est bien chez vous
Guillaume oui c'est chez moi oui est-ce
qu'on peut faire le showcase Sandy elle
est où elle est où Sandy ils sont répète
ils sont
répète merci c'est énorme les mecs oui
c'est son salon les chiens ils sont où
alors je sais pas ils sont où les
[Musique]
[Rires]
chiens comme tous les matins dans la
salle de bain
[Musique]
j'ai
sisoublié tu as résé j' en
pleur il me déranger tout ce qu'il l'a
dérangé en moins qu'un quart
[Musique]
d'heure je l'entends crier je lui amène
son café pour
[Musique]
lu ça fait des mois que ça du il m la
luure il me fait peur fait battre mon
cœur il me tape sur les nerfs mais voilà
le dilemme moi je
l'aime
pourquoi pourquoi de ça narrive qu'à moi
et pourquoi est-il tombé sur moi mais
qu'-je Don faire qu'-je d'en faire pour
mériter ça
pour pourquo pourquoi ça n'arrive qu'à
moi et pourquoi est-il tombé sur
moi maisje d'en
faireje d'
faireprend que j'aime
[Applaudissements]
ça il a une autre surprise il y a une
autre surprise chez Guillaume Janton
j'aimerais que le le cadreur aille dans
la chambre de Guillaume Janton pendant
que s dit continue à chanter merci on va
aller dans la chambre
on va aller dans la chambre de Guillaume
Janton s'il vous plaît parce qu'il y a
une autre surprise merci on va laisser
voilà on va laisser nos amis aller dans
la chambre alleer dans la chambre s'il
vous plaît dans la
chambre non mais alors ils vut aller
dans la
chambre voilà alors là voilà voilà ah et
qui
oh qui dans ta
J
on a tout V on a on a tout vu merci gu
c'est pour toi gu t'inquiè pas dans ta
chambre elle est très très
sympathique
éal Guillaume franchement tu vas kiffer
tu veux pas aller avec lui
chrop
ah là les chéis je sens franchement on
va se régaler ce Guillaum alors
attention parce que peut-être qu's vont
peut-être revenir ici ouais ou vont
peêtreir bien Sandy Valentino peut-être
une surprise Sandy Valentino et Riel
vont peut-être revenir juste pour te
voir magnifique g ça plaisir ou pas bah
oui mais ma meuf est où en fait j'ai pas
compris chi alors justement ta meuf on
va en parler un petit peu plus tard
parce que c'est pas tout à fait ce que
tu
crois allez on va revenir on va revenir
maintenant sur une image des années 90
j'espère vous passez un bon moment avec
il les 22h05 on est en direct on est là
pour encore longtemps il y a encore
beaucoup beaucoup de surprises notamment
pour vous autour de ce plateau et on va
revenir sur un des plus grands fourir de
l'histoire des JT la rivière prout après
ça toujours regardez Moldavie ancienne
république soviétique des inondations
d'une extrême importance ont fait au
moins 50 morts dans le centre du pays
pendant 2 jours des pluies torrentielles
se sont abatttu près de la capitale
chicino le niveau de la rivière La
proute s'est élevé de 5 m en quelques
heures à l'approche de l'Opel américain
quand il fut l'année dernière finaliste
le tenis français Cédric Pioline
retrouve la forme il s'est il s'est
qualifié pour la finale du tournoi de
Long Island dans la Blue de New York
c'est
incroyable les chéris on continue avec
une autre image c'est c'est une de mes
une des mes images préférées je crois
que c'est l'image où j'ai pas tapé la
plus grosse barre est-ce que vous
rappeler de l'émission mystère sur TF1
j'ai revu ça ça tourne beaucoup ça aussi
sur Youtube et c'est vrai que c'était
sensé re des trucs paranormaux sauf que
c'était toujours des truc éclaté au sol
et il y avait un bail c'est qu'en 94 il
y a un motard il y a un motard qui est
venu il a dit ouais j'ai des super
pouvoirs il arrive sur plat il arrive
sur plat il avait fait une vidéo où il a
les ux band où on le voit faire des
trucs de ouf donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
dit on va le tester au plateau frère et
doncve dit j'ai des super pouvoir je
peux voir je peux conduire je peux
piloter ma moto avec un bail avec un
masque sans rien voir frère je t'exque
l'expérience
second 14h25 Jean-Marie laforg arrive au
lieu de rendez-vous il ne semble
absolument pas nerveux son calme est
étonnant tout est prêt pour le départ et
sous nos yeux ébï Jean-Marie
démarre premier croisement si Jean-Marie
continue tout droit il percute la
camionnette rouge à gauche incroyable il
l'a évité nous avons invité trois
experts illusionnistes j'emploie donc
maintenant pour reculter ses yeux des
balles de cach mousse des cotons de
façon qu'il ne puisse pas voir je lui
souhaite beaucoup de succès mais j'en
doute
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
beaucoup exordinaire question suis
toujours posé pourquoi le gars av il
veut pas dire bon les gars on arrête on
arrête tout cé une les mecs non mais
sont rigolé le gars il faut tenter quand
même on sait jamais le gars il sait que
ça un total il sait que c'est un
imposteur mais le gars il veut la tenter
quand même vas-y on y va t'inquiète du
courage mais frère ça courage pour
démarrer c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire c'est extra ça c'est une
énorme ça franchement bravo aux équipes
parce que cellel j' vraiment envie qu'
la voir j'aiie